[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember it
so you don't have to when you're a kid a
lot of strange stuff seems normal
bicha Turtles was average tea parties on
the ceiling was mundane nothing forced
to dance in a banana sir drinking goat's
blood was just Tuesday Oh only my
parents had me do that should have asked
more questions regardless a lot of
things when you get older seemed
charming
some of them let me put in the whimsical
and champagne category obviously put in
what the hell was I thinking watching
this category and then there's those you
don't know where to put Japan's 1974
English dub of Jack and the Beanstalk
falls into that category of not knowing
the category like a fair amount of kids
I grew up with this bizarre adventure on
VHS it was available at a lot of rental
stores at the time we watched it it kept
us quiet and now we go about our
everyday lives but what we didn't know
was that what the crisis was leaving an
impact on our memories that years later
we'd say what that really is friggin
insane as I remember it I'm here to
report in for a Guinness starts off
similar enough jack is doing his chores
giving through the woods usual fairy
tale behind us we find out his dog used
to be part of a grand army I think he
has a symbolized collar that's similar
to an army he fantasizes about in the
clouds so there's that trust me that's
the least of the questions you will be
asking while watching this then part of
the course jack is asked to sell the cow
and comes across a mysterious man
playing a what I can only describe as a
70s machine either that or the snow pack
man makes me circuit 100 so Jack laughs
and then a man laughs and then he laughs
again
and then he must be Santa's number was
put on speed-dial of course health and
the magic beans after doing a dance
you set a cow which of course leads to
big shock huh she seemed nice this
pisses off the mother who punishes jack
and a common yet still uncomfortably
focused on manner you foolish Dawson
you're off head party job thanks to you
what readiness how cleaned when there's
Tommy to become beggars rubber become a
guru I worked up an appetite
child abuse just rumbles my tummy hmm me
GU that's just confusing
of course tosses them out the window
resulting in the Beanstalk rolling
you're one of many weird air signs
[Music]
always there must be a decent room maybe
mrs. s be do you stock singing in duet
Jack wakes up seeing the incredible
creation and of course climbs up the
bean store Emmaus princess climbs down
it as the story goes she explains what
happened to her in great detail but
there's one problem
it's told entirely in squeaks - I'm so
happy did not have subtitles was the
Star Wars Holiday Special
we agree never to play that again
finally Jack does climb the Beanstalk
and comes across a pretty yet somehow
disturbing image ha
she is a face that says I just joined a
cult and it's going great this is
Princess Margaret she literally was on a
cloud saying well random things
my parents were destroyed by an evil
witch I don't think about it it's been a
long time I'm happy now Jack you have
the worst Ranger danger
tomorrow I married my wonderful prince -
no I feel like reaching up to God
so if she ventriloquist or is this just
the song she's hearing in her mind right
now
where did you come into the castle with
me Jack I know Madame Hecuba would like
to meet you she says the princess kind
and beautiful mother would be happy to
meet him but discover she's not that and
now ladies and gentlemen that
uncomfortable fevered dream you had two
weeks ago a human child
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh it's been such a long long the
message of this movie is very
straightforward fear yeah definitely
shifted tones here didn't we as a valium
girl wasn't creepy enough we get Madame
heckuva pretty much every Disney witch
if she was stretched on a rack and fed
despair mother I'd like you to meet a
visitor Jack mhm no joke this will be
turns into a rather creepy haunted house
movie for a bit
you've been down too creepy singing in
the hallway lousy Pazuzu Tabernacle
Choir enjoy your meals you'll find it
delicious it's made from the finest
virgins she jumps in with plans to eat
them later because Hansel and Gretel
but her son comes in who it turns out is
the giant still set to Wed the princess
you see microd is under a spell to think
he's actually a handsome prince oh they
can become royalty so it's kind of like
Beauty and the Beast except ugly is bad
that's why they're ugly that's basically
to say moral right now cause she
squeezed him out but Jack wakes up
escapes and snoops around the castle
along with his dog and the capital mice
he comes across their Treasury and even
an amazingly annoying talking harp I
must be creamy hot you're supposed to
talk of all the things I've seen today
that's the weird stuff jack hides though
if the giant comes in and grabs a toy a
version of his mother okay
lines her up so she can insult him just
a baby good-for-nothing dump of love you
look like something someone left out in
the rain okay and then proceeds to smash
okay well that is kind of funny does he
have a lot of those does he smash one
every day am I supposed to be okay that
there's robots and Jack in the Beanstalk
I have so many questions I know I will
never get the answer to Jack decides to
steal the gold of course and go back
home where he shows his mom all the
riches he's gathered this looks like a
song for the dog mountains flowers who
have to climb a high don't you agree
and in case you're wondering no the dog
has never talked previous to the scene
and doesn't talk after it either and yet
he somehow has this big musical soul he
finds them really good oh I guess I
should be really harsh on that voice but
our dog is singing I really shouldn't be
that critical and what's Jack's reaction
to all this you can speak how come you
never said anything to me
mm-hmm maybe it's another miracle a sign
that I should have stayed to hell
sometimes it just takes a singing dog
yeah there was no other explanation
outside of that the dog singing was a
miracle a very very random miracle but
jack takes it as a sign to go back and
figure out how the snap Margaret out of
her trance and the pictures must be
kicked but by someone who is truly brave
and courageous only that would break the
fence someone truly brave gosh I wonder
if I'm brave enough to even cry you yeah
this kids possibly eerie we know Jack's
got to be like 9 or 10 or something like
that but they never say how old Margaret
is I guess old enough to marry but even
that varies in terms of time period and
location so well you might be feeling
awkward about not really knowing if you
should feel awkward about this don't
worry it will quickly disappear after
the strangest scene in the entire movie
just watch here in front of people
I are you happy it your wish to be
married now am i right
are you happy will you help each other
wrong you must tell me you have it up
[Music]
more sugar-frosted nightmares believe
what's being chanted crack pipe are we
watching here while the paper people
whoíll the trippy animation why met
preset sounds like he's getting his
testicles quit to a car battery every
other word are you happy none of this is
explained it will just pure madness to a
point where when Jack comes in and
finally kisses her you've totally
forgotten about the age thing it's not
even the spark in your mind all you're
thinking is are you happy are you happy
no I'm very confused and rather afraid
what is the kiss of course breaks the
spell and the giant chief is after them
okay you know where this is going to
giant chief is after ami cuts down the
Beanstalk and they live happily ever
after
what's not after an out of nowhere
totally pointless conversation between
our two heroes are you angry with me
I mean ember what I did angry now why
would I be angry with you just I
wouldn't blame you worried oh I know
what it yeah my kids are getting
restless can we wrap this up here they
run from the Giant again only to be
confronted by heckuva
[Music]
okay no joking I saw you at the end of
the shining hallway instead the two
little girls I'd be more afraid of you
but the giant comes in and weirdly
enough doesn't stop our heroes but
instead goes over to stop the mother
kind of randomly out of left field
it's made even stranger by the fact that
she's not technically under there but
the movie treatment like she's under
there he's right in front of her he said
goodbye he puts his foot down black
smoke comes out presumably destroying
her evil I guess
turning everyone else back to normal and
in the ultimate twist she was a robot
the whole time if you're confused by
these kids I'm sorry no adult can ever
help you
none of these ravings make any sense you
might as well put on a David Lynch film
to get a dose of reality but okay
Margaret has to stay with her people and
Jack has to go back home now leading to
him chopping down the Beanstalk and
killing the Giant right well in yet
another strange mood shift it suddenly
turns into a roadrunner cartoon
yeah with a slap stick his head getting
smacked in railroad tracks Tunnel the
whole thing
[Music]
it is like total Mad Libs like none of
the scenes are supposed to connect even
when we do get the climax of Jack
chopping down the Beanstalk
it still has soothing music that
obviously doesn't match
I feel like reaching up
oh man slaughter is beautiful and that
was in my opinion though weird is Jack
in the Beanstalk film is it any good
parts are there is a lot of good
animation backgrounds atmosphere
imagination but yeah it's pretty
inconsistent when it comes to story
characters and especially the tone but
honestly that's one of the things that
makes it so interesting the lack of
consistency makes it kind of hypnotizing
I can't think of any other fairytale
adaptation on the big screen which
choices this specifically odd so in a
weird way I do kind of recommend
checking it out if you're curious to
join in the madness like me you can find
it on DVD oh my god
find it on youtube take a look and get
sucked into an adventure you'll never
forget no matter how hard you try
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and are you
happy
[Music]
[Applause]
you